You doing okay? Good buddy
Called a suppressor, not a silencer
Your ears would be ringing- So loud
Like *painful moans*
A lot of things they get wrong
It's crazy out there man, the power just went out.
Everybody starts talking, we're trying to film a video
The thing is I was watching Altered Carbon last night, first episode, and the dude takes cover behind his kitchen cabinets
while guys fire high-powered rifles at him
It's like man those were some bulletproof cabinets
and that got me thinking about all the things that Hollywood gets wrong with guns
They get it wrong so many times and
*knocks on door*
Sorry
We've done a lot of videos of guns we film videos with airsoft guns a series with blank firing guns
That's Battlefield Rush. And we got out and we shot real guns a whole bunch
We've run the whole gamut from crappy fake plastic guns to the real deal and everything in between. You've gotten something, right?
We've gotten something's wrong
But I want to make a video ranting about Hollywood because that's a lot of fun to do
Understanding the things that Hollywood gets wrong about guns comes down to understanding
the mechanics of how they actually work the physics how the bullets fly and how the gun actually functions with like
Expanding gasses and pieces of metal and all that kind of stuff when you shoot a gun the recoil right it kicks back
It's not because the slide moves back it's not because of the expanding gases.
It's because of Newton's law of physics, "For every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction."
If you take a little piece of metal and you accelerate it
To like Mach 1 or Mach 2 or I don't know how fast this particular imaginary gun you're shooting its bullet
Let's just say you Mach 2 *laughs* you accelerate it to Mach 2
Well
That's a lot of force
Kicking back in the other direction and that's really what's causing your gun to kick up
and you can see the difference if you watch
somebody shooting a pistol out of pistol range
You'll see how much it kicks
versus how much a pistol kicks in a movie where they're using blanks
For example, in The Matrix.
He's firing two machineguns one-handed
they just went *gun plinking sounds*
getting a little bit of kick from the expanding gases of the blanks
But not nearly as much kick as you get in real life
Those things would go right up into the air if you try to shoot
real bullets out of those
but he is The One so whatever
Sam has an interesting story actually about sound
if somebody's more than say like-
200 meters away from you and they shoot at you
You'll actually see the muzzle flash first
then you'll hear the crack of the bullet flying by because the bullets traveling faster than the speed of sound and
Then you hear the bang of the gun.
So it's flash, crack, bang
like that.
Really weird
No one ever mixes their sound like that. They always get it wrong
In fact, we have a scene at the end of Rush where there's a sniper taking shots at somebody
Sam had to go into the sound booth himself and do the sound himself
*laughs*
Actually maybe we should go ask Sam about that experience real quick
I think it'd be really fun. Tell me how that works. And how movies get that wrong.
Oh boy.
I, Okay. Well first off I still have issues with that scene. It was like super rushed when we filmed it
I know "rushed" ha
It's- it's- it's littered with many issues. And so I'd say from a visual standpoint
It's not my finest work
but from an audio standpoint
I'd say it is.
I actually did the sound design for that scene as well as basically every other action scene in that series
"Karina..."
"You missed."
Here's how that works, when you're doing sniper fire
Basically, you're taking that same concept of rolling thunder and applying it to sniper rifles
The bullet is traveling
Faster than the sound of the rifle when you're approaching a sniper rifle scene where people are fighting with sniper rifles
People are not gonna shoot their guns a lot
You got to approach it with a way beefens up your sound you have to like make more with less so to speak
a really good way to do that is to get really nerdy with the physics of firing a sniper rifle at great distances.
The bullets generally travel much faster than the actual sound of the gunshot when heard or seen at a distance
*Bang*
So rather than just having a scene where the gun goes bang hit like that
You actually have a scene where it goes like this hit bang
Weird so it's like the gun shoots silently in the distance that you see a muzzle flash in the distance
You see a *stoonk*. You see the thing get hit and then suddenly you hear
*Gunshot fading off*
Like it's almost like rolling thunder
So now instead of just like one moment of gunfire
You're technically getting like three you're getting the original gunshot
You're getting the bullet impact incoming hit, whizz
ricochet all that stuff and then if you edit your scene
right you get to also have that
Of the gun firing in the distance as well. Kind of takes this one singular moment kinda spreads it out into this huge
meaty chunk
I think nerding out about this stuff makes the action more interesting because suddenly
Things don't work the way you're used to seeing them work
I guess the closer to realism you get the further away you get from like the Hollywood approach, the Hollywood approach kinda bland
at this point because it's so overdone
Necessity is probably the first thing in a sense that for the sake of certain scenes and narratives and storytelling technical physical aspects of
firearms into action and nerding out.
It's really not applicable doesn't really apply. It doesn't make the scene better
Sometimes you just want your hero to walk in and shoot everything and walk out unscathed because the point is
This guy's a hero, not here's how a gun works
Talking about suppressors? They get that wrong all the time
It's called suppressor not a silencer because there's nothing that silences the sound.
To not only mitigate the muzzle flash but to
suppress the sound. In John Wick 2, where they're walking like
*laughter and pew noises*
People just walking as if they don't hear it's like that would be so loud
But movies and always taught me that like suppressors were for stealth, but in reality it's for your hearing
Yeah
So you can be in like an urban situation or inside maybe without earplugs and not completely decimate your ears or the other
civilians that are around you. There are teammates or they're walking by this if you're shooting right next to a guy
You know blow his eardrums out with a regular gun
Which also calls into question like in all shows and all like movies and stuff people are shooting guns
without hearing protection
Especially like cop shows like
your ears would be ringing so hard.
Like you never see a movie where like an action hero
I was like before he goes and he's like-
*inserts earplugs*
Yeah, they should though.
There's a lot of things they get wrong
One thing I really like is and they did in The Matrix too - it's like they'll slow down the action
There'll be like half of the shots are like real-time other shots are like 30 frames a second and then other shots are like 48
And they blend it perfectly together
So it actually feels like it's like whoa
I could see like that little piece just a little slower because it's kind of fast, you know or like John Woo
He'll like play the same shot three times from different angles. Like I love I love that
I think it like it's such a cool pacing
a movie or somebody like taking cover behind like a cabinet and it's like stopping all the bullets from hitting them I think Die Hard 4 does that
Yeah with like tables and stuff
*laughs* We hide behind cardboard in Tacticool Reloads
Exactly. Jake just opens fire and they're hiding behind cardboard
With an AK!
Right?!
I think the worst thing in Hollywood movies. I mean, I don't really nitpick when it comes cause I'm just enjoying the movie
But if I weren't a nitpick, they would shoot off like 16, 17 rounds
How is this guy still shooting without reloading
So everything wrong with guns in Hollywood?
Racking the gun to mean you're you're serious and you mean business
have the gun pointed at somebody and they rack the gun
Either a bullet should pop out when that happens
Or just when they're pointing an empty gun at the person until you're active. Holding the hammer back kind of makes sense, though
It makes it easier to pull the trigger. When you pull the hammer back that generally means that your trigger pull is not as heavy
loudness, guns are super loud even with suppressors
They're still loud.
Jams never happen, reloading never happens, but I kind of get reloading, but John Wick 2 got that right
They got a lot of reloading in there. -...crazy though
I feel like in today's like society with video games like most people have a pretty good education
As far as like how to use a firearm, like what the firearms do, wouldn't you say so?
Yeah, but the biggest faults of video games they teach you that reloading your gun
Like like let's say you have 100 bullets and I have a 30 round mag and I shoot 5
So got 25 left reload, now I've got 95 bullets and what's really happening is you're throwing away those 25 bullets and then man
how the bullets just magically go into the other mag
That's why you should play Tarkov. Guns don't ever kick back in movies like they do in real life
Well if you're using blanks
you only have the expanding gases of the blank to cause kickback which is a lot less than if you're actually moving a piece of
Mass in one direction which causes the mass of the gun to move in the opposite direction if you're using airsoft then it's even weaker
Sparky, the gun guy on rush the gas the expanding gas from the sniper rifles
Especially coming out the side like you didn't make sure it's clear
You can't just put a camera off to the side of the gun. Oh, yes. It'll break the lens
Yeah people don't instantly die from getting shot
unless of course a shot in a very vital spot or you can get shot in the heart and you can still run for
A block. My grandpa was actually in a bank robbery. Not the robber. He was in the bank when it was robbed
So the robber put everybody into the vault and then locked the vault and then
You know grabbed the stuff and left. A cop was there and shot him and he shot him in the heart
The the robber and the guy ran for another two blocks before he dropped
Apparently, my grandpa has the bullet by the way, that's what my family's told me
Bullet penetration. That wouldn't be a hassle though for like
Hmm? Bullet penetration?
Yeah
That would be a pain
Yeah, you do like try to do a real bullet penetration. Your hero would never be able to take cover anywhere
You cannot hide behind a wooden table
You cannot hide behind cabinets. You cannot hide behind a car door. Drywall doesn't work either
Yeah, if you're shooting a 5.56 or a what 7.62 - dude. They will rip through those doors like like paper
They got it right in The Matrix though, when Morpheus is running and the agents shooting through the wall. That I love
That was a cool sequence. That's a smart move.
Yeah, that's right bullets don't penetrate water the only would penetrate like this far it's kind of crazy
Yeah, whenever is like getting killed in the water you'd be totally fine movies were like, you know, the hero jumps into the water
And they're like *Adrian's gun sounds* Yeah, that's not going to happen
Yeah, so guys if you're getting shot at, jump in the water. Go down a little bit you'll be a-ok
Now if they have bow and arrow you're fucked
Hey, just a quick reminder. We are judging the Light Dislocation Film Festival by Aperture
Do you want to know more about it or take part in it? Click the link in the description below!
Yes, I'm making a potato
And turning it into a camera.
Making a potato?
*laugh*
I'm carving a potato into a camera.
I didn't make a potato